solve for x and we have negative 16 is
less than or equal to 3x plus 5 which is
less than or equal to 20 s just to be
clear we could rewrite this if we want
as two separate inequalities or a
compound inequality we could write this
as negative 16 is less than or equal to
3x + 5 + + 3 x + 5 3x plus 5 is less
than or equal to 20 and you can solve
for x separately in each of these
inequalities and just remember that you
have that and to finish up with or you
can actually do the same operations on
every side of this to just have an X
sitting inside the middle so let's try
to do it that way since that'll be a new
way to look at this so let's let's
subtract since we want to isolate an X
in the middle of this compound
inequality let's subtract five from all
three sides from the left of the middle
and the right so let's subtract five
from there subtract five from here and
subtract five from here we don't have to
do anything to the inequalities because
we're just shifting it we're just
subtracting a number if you add or
subtract you want to do it you only have
to swap inequalities when you multiply
or divide by a negative number so the
left-hand side negative 16 minus 5 is
negative 21 negative 21 and then is less
than or equal to 3x plus 5 minus 5 is
just 3 x which is less than or equal to
20 minus 5 is 15 now we can divide all
three parts of this inequality by 3 once
again it's positive so it won't swap the
inequality so you divide them all by 3
and so here you get negative 7 is less
than or equal to x which is less than or
equal to 15 divided by 3 is 5 so you can
interpret this as X is between negative
7 and 5 including the boundaries or you
can write this as negative 7 is less
than or equal to X and X is less than or
equal to 5 and obviously this one we
could write at we could also write this
as X is greater than or equal to
negative 7 this is obviously the same
thing I'm just swapping both sides here
now if we want to graph this let's draw
our number line
let's draw our number line and let's say
that this right over here is negative
seven maybe 0 is over here maybe this is
5 over here we're going X is greater
than or equal to negative 7 so it will
it can be equal to negative 7 it's going
to be in this direction and X is less
than or equal to 5 so it can be equal to
5 and it's going to be in this direction
so you'd keep going all the way until
you get to negative 7 so this magenta
color is our solution set and let's
verify just by sampling a few points so
let's try out 00 should work if we put 0
here we get negative 16 is less than or
equal to 3 times 0 plus 5 is just 5
which is less than or equal to 20 this
is true 5 is greater than negative 16
and it is less than 20 so that works
let's try six because six should not
work so we get negative 16 is less than
or equal to 3 times 6 is 18 plus 5 is 23
which is less than or equal to 20 this
part works if you type if you put in six
but this is not true 23 is not less than
or equal to 20 so it's good that six
didn't work because six is not in our
solution set you could also try it out
with negative 8 negative 8 also should
not work let's try that out we have we
have negative 16 it should violate let's
try it out it we have negative 16 is
less than or equal to so if we put
negative 8 here this would be negative
24 plus 5 negative 24 plus 5 is negative
19 negative 19 is less than or equal to
20 negative 19 is less than or equal to
20 but it is not greater than negative
16 so this is not true so negative 8
also fails so we're feeling pretty good
about our solution